في ليبيا تمت افتراق بين مختلف اطراف
المشهد السياسي بشان ما يعرف بالقاعده
الدستوريه التي تحدد معالم وضوابط
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه المقبله
يمكن اجمال هذه الاطراف في المجلس الاعلى
للدوله الذي راسه خالد المشري ومجلس
النواب رئاسه عقيل صالح وحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه برئاسه عبد الحميد الدبيبه
وفعاليه سياسيه مختلفه يتطور المشهد تحت
اعين جهتين داخليه هي المجلس الرئاسي الذي
يقود الحكم حاليا في ليبيا ويعتبر نفسه
محيدا وبعثه امميه لليبيا يراسها السنغالي
عبد الله بطيلي فيظل انقسام الليبي اصدر
مجلس النواب ما عرف بالتعديل الثالث عشر
للاعلان الدستوري رسم التعديل المعلن نظام
الحكم في ليبيا بتشكيل سلطه تشريعيه تتكون
من غرفتين وسلطه تنفيذيه يراسها رئيس
المنتخب من الشعب ويكلف رئيسا للوزراء
اللافته هو ان التعديل لم يتضمن اي اشاره
الى شروط ترشح رئيس الدوله المثيره للجدل
ذلك على قوانين انتخابيه يفترض ان تصعب
التوافق في لجنه مشتركه من مجلس اي النواب
والاعلى للدوله مجلس الدوله وبعد مسار
متعثر وانقسام داخلي بين اعضائه صوت على
التعديل الدستوري وان قال رئيسه انه لن
يتنازل عن موقفه بضروره منع مزدوج الجنسيه
والعسكريين واعضاء السلك القضائي من
المشاركه في الانتخابات في حين يرفض مجلس
النواب وضع هذه الشروط فيما يبدو لترك
الباب مفتوحا امام ترشيح خليفه حفتر
بالموازات اعتبر رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبيبه ان اي قاعده
دستوريه يجب ان تطرح للاستفتاء امام الشعب
الليبي وانه لا عوده للحكم العسكري مجددا
لليبيا اقرار هذا التعديل الدستوري وفقد
بيبا لا يتوافق مع ما اقترحه باتيلي على
مجلس الامن الدولي بتشكيل لجنه وصفها
بالتوجيهيه تتولى صياغه خريطه طريق
للانتخابات هذا العام قوى سياسيه ايضا
رفضت التعديل ونبهت لمسمته مخاطر الانزلاق
المستمر في مسار التنازلات والاخلال
بالتوازن المطلوب في التوافق الوطني توافق
يبدو ايضا غائبا بشان من ينظم الانتخابات
فالمجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب
يطالبان بحكومه مصغره وموحده لتنظيم
الانتخابات بينما يؤكد دبيبه ان حكومته
اكثر قوه اليوم للتعبير عن اراده الليبيين
لانهاء المراحل الانتقاليه وتنظيم
الانتخابات المقبله